[Music]
here we have the nine most powerful
monsters of morgoth from the works of
tolkien a couple of them seen in the
movies melkor or morgoth was a valor a
godlike being who was the original dark
lord of middle earth and he created many
servants that were deadly monsters and
here are nine of them at number 9 we
have te vildo in baron and luthien and
other early stages of tolkien's
legendarium tavildo the prince of cats
was the mightiest of all felines and
possessed an evil soul this large cat
was a companion of morgoth tavildo's
physical appearance included being black
as the starless knight and having
blood-red eyes and also said to be
massive in size devildo was also given a
mystical color made of gold that
enhanced his powers even further
number 8 gargareth
there were werewolves in durkin's works
which are sometimes confused with walks
anyway even though the first werewolf
was called dragluin the most powerful of
them was gargareth a morocco's own hands
breaded from living flesh and filled it
with immense and terrible power
so-called carrot also known as unfoglier
the jaws of thirst grew to an enormous
size and his might look unrivalled his
eyes glowed like red embers in the night
and his fangs were as poisonous as the
orcish legion spears
number seven turing wethel if there's a
werewolf then there is also a vampire
and the most well known was during
wether who was a mario spirit of firstly
and that was corrupted by morgoth and
decided to follow the dark lord and
later was a servant of sauron as well
during wethel was sauron's herald
stationed at dol in goroth by the time
of the quest of the silmarils she was
probably slain there in the fight
between sauron and huan the hound she
took the form of a vampire and also that
of a large bat
number 6 durian's bane
it was one of the mayor spirits that
fell with the valar before the world was
founded melkor ultimately enticed it and
corrupted it and it became one of the
valerokar joining the other balrogs and
morgot servers this bellrock most
certainly fought in several engagements
during the war of the jewels
and notably in the war of wrath it
escaped margaret's downfall by escaping
eastwards and seeking safety beneath the
misty mountains the dwarves of moria
reawaken it in the third age and the
fellowship of the ring encountered it
again ending in battle to death with
gandalf
number five glaurum
bred by morgoth in order to break an elf
siege on his fortress glaurum was a
flightless dragon that wreaked havoc on
the armies of the first age
he was also the first terrestrial
fire-breathing dragon and was known as
the father of dragons tolkien described
glaurung as a quarter fetal reptile
without wings similar to chinese dragons
or crocodiles
he was a terrible creature who
annihilated an entire elven army
therefore at the very least he had to be
greater than smog for this to happen
number four anne gallagher on the black
the biggest of the dragons to ever
appear in middle earth he was one of the
most powerful servants of the dark lord
and caligon the black was bred in order
to turn the tide of the war of wrath and
was almost able to do it he alongside
other smaller dragons drove back the
army of the angelic valor that came to
middle-earth the most intriguing thing
about him is his size as he destroyed
the volcanic mountains of tarangordrim
when he was slain and fell into them he
was slain by arendell and the great
eagles he was also stated to have the
most powerful fire amongst dragons and
balrogs
number 3 gotham
originally a myra spirit that was
corrupted by margaret and became one of
the valaroka
the bellrocks and during the first age
gothmock was the lord of the bellrocks
and the greatest balrog to ever walk the
lands of middle earth he was margot's
frontline lieutenant and one of his most
valuable subordinates holding the high
rank of high captain of angban he fought
calnus battles in the name of his master
and was directly responsible for the
deaths of two of the naldor's high kings
he was vanquished in the siege of
gondolin but was also able to kill his
opponent an elflord called xtelion
number 2 sauron known better as the dark
lord or the lord of the rings he was the
most daring maya the creator of the one
ring a renowned disciple of the valar
aule and margaret's most loyal servant
following margot's defeat by the valor
sauron rose to become the second dark
lord attempting to conquer middle earth
and even numenor by trickery although he
might not be the most physically
powerful as compared to the dragons or
gothmuck he is the second in command due
to his vile cunning and being a master
strategist as well as having an
indomitable will
and number one the most powerful
angolian
she was a primordial creature taking the
form of a massive spider she was
initially margaret's ally in amman and
for a little period in middle-earth as
well she was shelob's distant mother as
well as artha's oldest and first
enormous spider even the valor had no
idea where angeline came from she is
really old older than the mire
themselves it is supposed that she
emerged from the darkness that
surrounded arda the primal world
although originally being a servant or
ally of morgoth she eventually turned
against him and almost subdued him if
not for the help of the balrogs that
drove away from morgoth
so that's it i hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit the like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash the bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel
till the next one
take care fam